Chris wrote to me and said hey David can
you go into detail on your show about
your rationale behind why you invested
in Tesla how do you think how high do
you think the stock could go what are
the reasons you think it could go higher
do you agree it could be a riskier stock
because it's not yet turning a profit or
meeting demand I understand you're not a
financial advisor but it would be
interesting to hear your take I I need
I'll all deal with this but I need to
address once again I am NOT a financial
advisor nothing I say on the show is
advice in terms of investment and uh
that full stop this nothing i'm going to
say is investment advice I basically
don't invest in individual stocks I have
I have very little individual stock
ownership and I've talked many times I
think really very few people uh can time
the market and very few people can
really pick stocks and if you look at
this just as many hedge funds and uh
whatever else are underperforming the
broader indexes as over performing and
that's just a basically an example of
the reality that over the longer and
longer term that you look at this you're
going to be better off just with mutual
funds that follow indices that being
said I believe in what Elon Musk is
doing I believe that big picture Tesla
is a company that is going to to borrow
a word from Donald Trump here win
whatever that means and I get it you
could come to me and say you know the
thing is David Tesla's not even turning
a profit yet and already a dozen ten
maybe more like eight different car
manufacturers are going to have vehicles
that are essentially just as self
piloting as Tesla by 2018 or the latest
2020 so they're not even doing anything
innovative yet so uh I don't think it's
about that I think it's more about
believing in elon musk's track record
believing in the approach that he is
taking to the company and you know what
it's pretty damned risky any time you
invest in an individual stock it is
risky I invested very little in it I
don't know whether in the end I will end
up making any money or not I am warned
the warren buffett camp of the ideal
holding period is forever and that's it
i'm not i'm not a stock trader I very
little money in stocks uh so yeah I mean
I give my disclosure anytime we
about Teslin say full disclosure I'm a
shareholder here but uh it is more
because I like to invest in companies
that big picture I believe are doing
things that will be big that will be
huge overall and it's not about looking
at for me at their uh profit and loss
statement or anything like that so
that's the big picture I wish I could
say more I don't know how I could go I
am or overall bullish on the tesla stock
price who knows what the timeline would
be could be five years could be ten
years I really don't know I'm not really
making a case for people did not only
did I say Jason that this is a
disclaimer that I'm it's not financial
advice I'm not even telling people to
invest in tehsil I'm basically saying I
did and I'm just planning on holding it
indefinitely I was told one of the
things was very important about them
entering the market becoming company is
they kind of forced all these other car
manufacturers to step into this market
as well and there's many other viable
cheap options like the leaf yeah it for
a lot of like Ford has hybrids everyone
has a hybrid now because they need to
compete with Tesla and actually at a
better price point may not be as sexy
and as cool as you know this uh suicide
door or the uh you know that yeah it
that one at school is that yeah but but
Lisa force them to do it yeah I i agree
with you and uh that's my answer and I'm
sticking to it and you know what I might
lose all my money and uh that's why I
say very clearly this is not investment
advice we will take a break on the bonus
show today should capitalist economics
be the only economics taught in school
india's richest man offers free 4g
internet to a billion people and obama
announces 90 million dollars to clear
laos Laos is I think that's the right
pronunciation unexploded bombs those
stories and more on the bonus show
remember david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up and get
instant access